اهلا بكم قال مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائيل بودالياك انها حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا ستنتهي دون اي تنازلات اوكرانيه
مؤكدا ضروره حصول بلاده على مساعدات فعاله
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره لمناسبه دخول الحرب
على اوكرانيا عام ثاني اضافه ان هناك صيغه
واحده للسلم عرضها الرئيس زيلينسكي وهي
خروج روسيا من كل الاراضي التي احتلتها
منذ عام 1991
[موسيقى]
قبل البدء باي مفاوضات يجب ان تقوم روسيا
بشيء واحد يجب ان تخرج تخرج من جميع
الاراضي الاوكرانيه وبعدها ممكن فعلا ان
نبدا باي مفاوضات حتى نتحدث عما نقوم به
فيما بعد هناك صيغه واحده للسلم هي الصيغه
التي عرضها السيد زيلينسكي وتبدا هذه
الصيغه من خروج روسيا من جميع الحدود
الاوكرانيه منذ عام 91 بما فيها الدنباص
وشبه جزيره القرم
وقال مستشار رئاسه الاوكرانيه ان بلاده
تواصل سعيها مع واشنطن لتسليمها طائرات
مقاتله من اجل مواجهه اله الحرب الروسيه
واضاف انك لمست مؤشرات ايجابيه من الجانب
الامريكي ازاء تسليمها تلك المقاتلات
قريبا
تعلمون المفاوضات تسير بشكل فعال كل حرب
لديها مراحل مختلفه في كل مرحله يجب ان
نستخدم اليات معينه بالنسبه للطائرات
العسكريه هذه مرحله مهمه في هذه الحرب
اؤكد ان روسيا الان تقوم بقصف جميع المدن
في دولتنا العشرات من المدن حيث الملايين
من السكان تقوم بقصف هذه المدن بصواريخ
مجنحه وصواريخ باليستيه
وصواريخيه ممكن تدميرها فقط بطائرات
عسكريه 16
ونرى الان مؤشرات ايجابيه من الولايات
المتحده ان هذه الاسلحه من الممكن تسليمها
بفترات قصيره لاوكرانيا